in this video we're gonna take a look at
the limits when you're given a graph
such as this one and let's take a look
at the first one see if you can do these
on your own and we'll go through them
number one the limit as X approaches
negative five of this function f of X so
when we look at negative five right here
on our graph you can see when you're
approaching the graph from the left side
and you can see when you're approaching
that negative five from the right side
and you can see the one is going down
towards negative infinity the other side
is going up towards positive infinity
you can see that there's like this
infinite gap here this what they call a
non removable discontinuity it's
basically an infinite discontinuity so
here we're going to say does not exist
and if you want to say more you can say
it's an infinite discontinuity or it's
unbounded one of those would be fine for
number two the limit as X approaches
negative 5 from the C this little minus
sign that means from the left so when
we're approaching negative 5 here from
the left side what are the Y values
getting closer and closer to so when you
see that f of X think about what is the
Y getting closer to the Y values you can
see are going down towards negative
infinity okay for number three we've got
the limit as X approaches negative 5 and
you see that little plus sign that's
from the positive side from the right
side so we're approaching negative 5 but
here we're approaching from the right
and you can see that the Y values are
going up up up towards positive infinity
okay but notice when you approach to the
right and from the left since they're
approaching two different values that's
why we just said that when you were just
approaching negative five that's why the
limit didn't exist because the left-hand
limit and the right hand limit didn't
match they weren't the same so for
number four the limit as X approaches
infinity of f of X so you can see here
as we go to the right okay as X is
getting larger and larger as we're
approaching positive infinity what
happens to the Y values where you can
see they're going down down down down
towards negative infinity okay and for
number five the limit as X approaches
negative infinity okay so you can see
here when we're approaching the left
side of the graph so as X is getting
smaller and smaller as its approaching
negative infinity what happens to the Y
value
we can see it's going up up up but it
starts to become almost like a
horizontal line it's approaching this
dashed or dotted line and it looks like
that y-value is at positive 1 so you can
see that the limit here is going to be
positive 1 okay for number 6 the limit
as X approaches negative 4 of the
function okay where is negative 4 right
here as you're approaching from the left
it looks like you're getting closer to
this open circle here which has had a
y-value of 1 and the limit as X
approaches negative 4 from the right
side okay so when you're going this
direction you can see it's also pushing
that same hole which has a y-value of 1
now when you're talking about limits
you're getting closer and closer but you
don't actually reach negative 4 so if
they asked us what is f of negative 4
that would be doesn't exist because
there's not a point there but the limit
as X approaches negative 4 since we're
approaching the same y-value from both
sides of positive 1 that's our limit for
number 7 what's the limit as X
approaches 0 okay now you can see here
I've tried to illustrate this by hand
but you can see when you're approaching
zero from the left side when you're
approaching 0 from the right side do you
see how it's bouncing back and forth
between negative 2 and positive 2 okay
even if you were to zoom in on this
let's say this was on a graphing
calculator you would still see that like
a ricochet effect where it's passing
back and forth between negative 2 and
positive 2 so it's not approaching you
know one constant value so that means
this is going to be does not exist and
you could say that that's oscillating
okay oscillating so that limit doesn't
exist number 8 the limit as X approaches
negative 3 of the function okay so
where's negative 3 it's right here okay
and notice when you're approaching
negative 3 from the left it looks like
you're getting closer to 0 and as you're
approaching negative 3 from the right
side you're getting closer to negative 1
so it looks like there's not a limit
here since you're approaching two
different Y values as you get closer to
x equals negative 3 this is also going
to be does not exist and this is if you
want to be more specific this is what's
called them a non removable
discontinuity I mean we just can't put
like a point right there and fill that
hole and make it continuous it's you
know one point it's not going to be
enough to bridge that gap we call this a
jump discontinuity
okay so you can either say it does not
exist or if you want to see a little bit
more jump discontinuity for number nine
the limit as X approaches negative three
from the left okay so here we're
approaching negative three but from the
left side you can see routing closer to
a y-value of 0 and the limit as X
approaches negative 3 from this see this
plus sign from the positive or the right
side you can see you're getting closer
and closer to this Y value here of
negative 1 and that's why we said that
it didn't exist for number eight because
they were approaching two different Y
values and then the last question number
11 the limit as X approaches 2 of the
function okay so here as X is
approaching two when you're approaching
from the left side you're approaching
from the right side they're both
approaching that same y-value of 0 so
you can see there's really no gap here
there's no jump there's no missing point
it's actually just continuous at 2 and
you can see the limit is as you approach
2 from the left side and the right side
is the same and that Y value remember
when you think of f of X think of what
the Y value is that Y value is zero and
you got it so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did subscribe to the
channel check out more of my videos on
my Mario's math tutor and YouTube
channel and I look forward to helping
you in the future videos I'll talk to
you soon